didier maïsto bonsoir mantois
alors on l'a vu un effondrement du taux
de participation ce soir l'élection
municipale c'est l'une des principales
informations
dans ce contexte là quelles valeurs on
les résultats les estimations ce soir
alors d'abord je ne commenterai
évidemment pas les résultats
parce que ces résultats n'ont aucune
valeur et le bon qu'il est venu toute la
soirée c'est surréaliste
surréaliste on est en train de commenter
l'élection municipale dans tous les gens
sensés avaient averti qu'ils aient
qu'elle ne devait pas se tenir
le corps médical dans son ensemble les
pas n'importe qui un les chefs de
services des hôpitaux parisiens les plus
en pointe sur le sujet on on danse cessé
d'alerter et là ce soir comme des
playmobil vous avez tous les étudie ce
qui nous tue c'est le comité ce qu'il
anticipait un comité scientifique
il ya les tunnels et des gants enfin de
quoi parle-t-on
ce soit il ya une explosion des morts
parce que tous les gens étaient dans les
parcs cédés des ponts-de-cé l'as fait
sortez se balader aller voter le tout le
monde tous les professeurs ce soir de
médecine disent que ça participer de
façon active et galopante à
l'augmentation de l'épidémie il n'y a
qu'une chose à faire ce soir c'est le
confinement street est totale et c'est
respecter ces mesures
j'ai lu toute la journée des gens qui
disaient sur les sur les réseaux dans
les télévisions a mais il ya plus de ya
pas plus de risques il ya moins de
risques de te veux aller voter que
d'aller faire ses courses
enfin plus c'est plus dans mon pays et
dans tous les pays du monde ça fait plus
c'est pas parce qu'on va pas ajouter du
désordre et de l'épidémie à laquelle
allait à l'épidémie avance un moment
c'est juste ce réaliste je ne comprends
pas quand le discutant on discute encore
de ces j'ai entendu à l'instant anne
hidalgo qui appelle qui se féliciter
d'être en tête etc
mais c'est c'est indécent surréaliste et
gégé j'ose le mot ces criminels
maintenant il faut que tout le monde se
ressaisissent que la catholique
ce re se ressaisissent et dès demain
déclare le confinement strict et que
tout le monde reste chez soi c'est ainsi
qu'on a qu'on pourra lutter contre la
maladie contre l'épidémie
127 morts déclarés en france ce soir
situation extrêmement catastrophique en
italie on s'acheminerait vers un
scénario à l'italienne en france et ce
que disent les épidémiologistes
vous pensez que les français ne sont pas
suffisamment discipline et finalement ou
est ce que c'est la confusion du
gouvernement qui fait que les français
ne prennent pas l'ampleur du problème
si vous voulez il ya quand même une
confusion gouvernementale
le problème depuis depuis quelques jours
le gouvernement ne cesse de vous dire
que ces scientifiques qui est un comité
scientifique
il a peut-être ça un peu comme un mantra
ces scientifiques les scientifiques
bon le problème si vous voulez c'est que
les vrais scientifiques les gens avertis
etc n'ont cessé d'avertir et n'ont cessé
de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé en disant
il faut pas que c'est l'élection
soutiennent ils l'ont dit un peu plus
fort ce soir parce que bon le processus
était enclenché qui voulait pas affoler
la population
si vous dites aux gens écoutaient dormez
braves gens la situation est gérée
il ya un comité et c'est la seule chose
qu'on sait en termes d d'épidémiologie
en terme d'épidémie
moi je suis pas scientifique mais je
m'entoure de gens autorisés à parler à
réfléchir
la seule chose que l'on sait faire et on
sait bien le faire c'est podetti vais
donc c'est pas nouveau on n'a pas
découvert sain entre avant-hier et
aujourd'hui on fait exactement la montée
de la courbe
on savait exactement à quelle que
quelques dizaines de ces unités de
personnes quelles seraient les résultats
et quelles seraient les cibles ce soir
c'est pas que cette épidémie c'est pas
que celui ci particulièrement nocifs
on va s'en sortir je veux pas non plus
affoler les gens il faut bien comprendre
comment ça fonctionne
c'est à dire que plus on prend moins en
prend deux mesures adaptées plus le
titre sera rapide et ou bien comprendre
ça il ya une capacité de lits
la capacité de lits il faut pas qu'elle
soit saturé il ya un certain nombre de
respirateurs parce que comment on en
meurt ça fait des complications
respiratoires
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails ont
donc on meurt par étouffement dans si
les leviers sont saturés si les gens qui
peuvent être sauvées ne peuvent pas
bénéficier de respirateur artificiel
ils vont mourir c'est aussi simple que
cela et c'est vraiment indécent de voir
aujourd'hui les verts les jaunes et
bleus les rouges compter les points dans
une élection qui qui n'aurait pas dû
avoir lieu qui est indécente ans dont la
maison brûle comme disait l'autre et on
regarde ailleurs
et ce soir tout le monde se félicite que
la démocratie a été sauvé et c'est que
les gestes essentiels rod est assurée
c'est pas du tout le cas parce que quand
vous avez autant de gens qui vont voter
de maths de façon inconséquente on ne
peut pas respecter toutes les consignes
de sécurité
il ya des pleins des bureaux dans le sud
mais tu n'es pas que ça ne veut pas
simplement que dans le sud à marseille
et ailleurs où il n'y avait pas de gand
où il ya des tas de deux dispositifs de
gel ou les règles et les gestes
barrières n'étaient pas respectées mais
c'est inhérent à tout déplacement massif
tout le monde peut comprendre st donc il
est temps que les gens se reprennent
parle d'autre chose abandonne cette idée
mortifère de deuxième tour je pense que
de toute façon on y va et maintenant
c'est une course contre la montre il
faut que chacun s'est ténue c'est
insupportable c'est c'est compliqué on
est un peuple social on envie de faire
la fête pendant quinze jours trois
semaines 1 - le temps qu'il faudra il
faut se discipliner il faut c'est
discipliné et ne pas rester chez soi ne
pas avoir de monde parce que je
j'entends aussi comme un leitmotiv
le virus circule le vieillissement le
virus ne circule pas le ce sont les
personnes qui circulent et ce sont les
personnes qui peuvent en contaminer
d'autres ce qu'a dit le pr nordmann le
premier mystère dont le premier ministre
l'a dit d'ailleurs il l'a dit ce n'est
pas le virus qui circule ce sont les
personnes qui circulent donc on a du mal
à le problème maintenant le problème
c'est qu'ils disent ils disent on ne
demande pas au premier ministre au
président de la république d'être des
commentateurs de la vie politique
on leur demande pas de consulter les
partis politiques gérard larcher les
républicains le rassemblement national
et tous les autres partis politiques
maintenant tout le monde le sait le
monde médical le sait on a l'exemple de
la chine on a l'exemple de l'italie à
nos frontières le thalys et nous les
italiens c'est nous c'est là mais c'est
à peu près le même pays c'est juste à
côté on voit on voit les courbes elles
progressent exactement de la même
manière
donc c'est pas comme si on ne savait pas
tout le monde le sait donc maintenant
dès demain qu'il faut agir pour arrêter
d'attendre merci beaucoup didier maïsto
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france ce soir